ich habe ich habe auf kreis- gedrückt da
hat man mich als beifahrer gesehen ich
habe einen deutlichen stimme wie man die
car is aber mega star der bis jetzt
immer noch viel
ich habe auch noch nie geschafft meine
katzen so blöde einem eimer alt ich habe
auch kein irgendwie helfen
ich habe aber ich habe diese skills
alter du hast ja ich war hier richtig
gestartet
ja ja das war doch alles nur geplant ja
und jetzt jetzt jetzt kommt ziemlich gut
jetzt gehen wir nicht da hinten ist
kiloweise wird doppel bilden verlierst
oder schlecht ist wie ich es mir
vorgestellt hatte
wieso verein wenn überall kopf sind ja
das ist gut die kopf denkt der denkt ihr
kopf
der fährt hier nicht rein aber dann
fahre ich da rein sondern das geht aber
nicht lange überlebt schon nicht richtig
kann ich gar nicht länger her ich habe
ständig du hast ein ständer ich habe ich
habe auf kreis- gedrückt da hat man mich
als beifahrer gesehen ich habe einen
deutlichen stimme ja hab mir leid ich
bin so aufgeregt aber die wollen sie
nutzen
du hast schon das passt gut denn viele
der hand ich hab' ich muss mir unter
waffen haben ich habe nichts mehr
du hast auch schon höre
nein die kannst du mich ist porto heli
ja jetzt fährst du einmal ein faktor und
das gilt ja sagst du jetzt mit der karte
wirst auch nicht klarkommen kann nicht
mehr kürzen bisschen entspannen ein
ja ich habe dann gefragt was willst du
das nicht ein bisschen entspannen
sterben
[Musik]
die lasse ich einfach so schon verloren
münchen nur menschen 81
ich glaube dass man ja die zu langsam
geworden
oh mein gott ja weiter gefahren zu
meinem zu meinem mobil auf dem mac gibt
mir gib mir die karte
das problem ist jetzt direkt vom mars
mission steht ein junger geiger steht
ein richtig geiles motorrad aber nicht
denn hier ist mein
das ist richtig geil ich will auch so
ein kleiner haben das schnelle ja das
ist die jetzt hier und umsonst dlc ja
das ist das was sie bestimmt auch das
war so ein update geht der online update
dann konnte man sie so ein boot und ein
zumba die 50
aber du hast das doch nur bekommen weil
ja ja ja muss man ein handy browser
gucken und dann bei bei autos gibt es
dann so ein einen anbieter gibt es ein
bisschen was umsonst so ein armer bauer
wäre ich der ist auf der b5 können wenn
der erste auf level 5
ich denke wir haben ja immer noch dass
man das kommt kann ihn das coni ja könnt
ihr das kopf gab aber beeil dich von
undercover zu sagen von comscore
verfolgt und ich bin im kopf alt hat
eine karre den reifen ist ab ich muss
auch daran
aber sie fährt noch ein bisschen mehr
ich war freut sich jetzt auch mit dem
kopf mobil werden ich muss ihnen das ist
jedenfalls mein stil weiter wie viele
straßen blieben folglich werden
auf was kommt schon bullen in meinem
wagen direkt würde ich steig sein
kollege
ich lenke einmal die ganze klasse
bekommt kaum stärker stellen einfach
darum ich hab keinen bock mehr auf die
mini würde ja aber ein wenig gab alle
nicht ich verstehe ich verstecke mich
jetzt hier neben dem offenen wagen
darunter gehe ich jetzt hast du immer
noch deutsch lernen
ja du hier versteckt mich jetzt befinde
mich keiner wo ich werde von allen
seiten gefordert junge fußgänger die
polizei vor bei denen nicht einfach
nicht die behinderten kommen kommt ja ok
wollen bin ich los
dort möchte ich stehe hier also ich
bewegte mich einfach mal nicht im gucken
auf post wohin es mich ja die beiden
sind aber direkt neben dir hier und ich
gerade ab das bringt ja auch gar nicht
aber ich könnte ja ich war zu meiner
karre und geben zu lassen das casting
sind repariert
aber wenn du so habe ich jetzt nicht
gegen kommt man auch einfach dahin mit
deiner karte mit der ich glaube dahinter
das war mir danach machen wollen wir
danach mit jetskis uns gekommen machen
ich bin reagieren was ja ich versuche
das mit den cops hier abzuschicken
übrigens leute ich versuche jetzt in
dieser folge dass der star ich bin mal
wieder 30 geil also gta lauter jonas
besser jetzt bestellen und full hd naja
ich bin so blutig hast du einen tage
oder so überall ist blut verankert
werden
doch mein gott ich ziemlich karte
ok
mit dieser karte sind unglaublich aber
die sga lackiert sowie mobil so gelten
weil ich es wohl folgen kann da sauer
weiß rot grün gelb mobil so ich gehe
jetzt erstmal des kastens naja ich habe
ein feuerwehrmann bei der nächste ist
der weg wo mein gott auf ein habe ich
wieder 112.000 ich verstehe ich warum oh
mein gott meine karre sieht einfach aus
zu sein batmobil aber fährt nicht so
traurig
[Musik]
nach dem wechsel gleich zu dem gleichen
voix du kannst so gut kombinieren alter
bringt ihr das gerät wird gabi gehen gar
nicht weiter weil da kann ich jetzt des
kastens besetzen so dass du nicht kannst
du ja was bringt mir das personal und
dann okay okay wir können auch einfach
aber gut
das hat die länge eines beach bar ist
bei ihm so lange wie ein fahrrad fahren
und mein gott ich bin jetzt in lausanne
descas teams drin ohne ein auto zu
ehrlich ja weil du das auch gemacht hast
du dich hier war ein gewinn
was willst du von mir
traurig aber wahr läuft bei die jungs
haben jetzt steig ein hast du bist
wieder hinfällig
schlagloch
okay okay kein thema
ich bin jetzt noch ein punkt wurden
einfach was ich bin okay genau wie
kleine kinder über die schulter
[Musik]
mit den zwei sterne
ich mag nie zuvor ich hab mein
controller liegt auf dem tisch
genau das ist gerade entspannende kiwi
während du hier siehst du den wegpunkt
ja na ja also ich verstecke mich aber
mal ganz kurz hier das ist megageil
versteckt was mich so wenn du dich denn
jetzt fahren wie eine frau ich kann mir
auch gut einparken
das ist natürlich richtig anpacken so
ein bisschen feingefühl maßnahme ganz
eng gefor zurück vor zurück dass kerzen
vor
hey ich bin das geht ja jetzt was dazu
so strasser nicht gegen meine frage
nicht gegen meine fast genau das wieder
einstellen da glaube ich wenn meine
treffen wäre dann oh mein gott alles hat
so gelegt ich höre dir guckst du in der
aufnahme alles hat gelegt doch jetzt
rudi alter den kopf gestoßen guck dir
meine fast gilt an alter ich bin das ist
richtig feiern
die sind richtig noch existent ich finde
richtig geil ich gemerkt was spielen sie
benutzen
ja die gisa wo sie jetzt jetzt jetzt ein
bisschen warum schreiben wir suchen
jetzt einfach welchem ich habe mir jetzt
gekauft aber ich weiß nicht wie es hätte
so schön sein können
oh mein gott nehme so nach vom fiel ja
ihr kommt nochmal du hast irgendwie kein
motor der motor beim lamborghinis hinten
dort wurden wir auch alle die kommentare
geschrieben
sie ist ferner muss
aber dann habe ich so wenig nicht das
mache und auch alltours
ich hab jetzt eigentlich weh
was war wo war da die idee ich wo habe
dass kontakte ich habe den knopf hier
hochgezogen weil er in frage käme ich
habe den knopf hier so hoch gezogen dass
ich vielleicht so ein bisschen höher
springe aber nein ist es nicht klappt ja
ok wo könnt ihr jetzt wie sie vielleicht
am strand und nicht mitten auf dem
parkplatz erwartet
hier müsste eigentlich sein da wo die 1
das nietzsche switches waren vielleicht
ich habe mich stark von dir hier hoffen
dass seine brennt deaktiviert er selbst
erfolgreich so lange geschlossen
kannst du das irgendwie erklären jetzt
ist er nur ein jet ski läuft jetzt hab
ich hätte jetzt kann ich nämlich immer
das machen würde
junge du hast die zeit
ich habe nicht mehr darauf geschossen
ach so ich auch nicht ich hab noch nicht
mal eine waffe in der hand als ob du
wirklich du hast du wirklich nicht
geschaffen die ohne witz ich habe mich
aber auch nicht geschossen
ja irgend jemand redet hier auch wert
all das wird ein spannendes rennen wenn
wir beide hier auf eine bürgerin leider
bei mir redet keiner mehr jetzt auch
oder zusichert wie kann ich das
ausstellen einer redet
statt online nicht dass ich hier wieder
leute beschweren selecta online optionen
doch ich glaube du hast schon chat auf
cool gemacht oder freund sondern
persönlich und ich habe es auch ich habe
ja doch niemand gemacht
okay da ist es gibt so ein easter egg
angeblich das wenn man eigentlich
zufolge wird vorbei ja ok in der
nächsten folge zeigen wir euch dann aber
wir haben schon eine halbe stunde haben
gehen 30 minuten
wir haben in der nächsten folge zeigen
euch dann richtig geiles easter egg was
man hier auf dem wasser machen kann es
hat etwas mit einheit zu tun